Що станеться, коли ми помремо?
Більшість з нас не хоче навіть замислюватися над цим.
Питання не лише в тому, хто і що успадкує в реальному житті.
Багато людей ведуть також активне віртуальне життя -
в десятках акаунтів: профілі в Інстаграмі, Фейсбуці, онлайн-банкінг…
Але що станеться з цими даними після нашої смерті?
Ні, я не думала про це. Адже фотографії - це теж спадщина.
Зараз я роздруковую їх на папері та збираю в  альбом для своєї доньки.
Я ще не настільки старий, щоб думати про смерть.
Це складна тема. Я уже особисто стикалася з таким:
один із моїх знайомих помер і постало питання - що буде з його акаунтом у Фейсбуці?
Я не знаю. Можливо, я попрошу когось видалити мій акаунт.
Ніколи про це не думав.
Уже навіть почали зявлятися спеціальні фірми, які допомагають близьким і родичам
знаходити "сліди" померлих у мережі і видаляти їхні акаунти.
Людина помирає і залишає по собі договори, приміром, з онлайн-провайдером.
Той не знає, що абонента вже немає,
тому й далі стягує гроші, витрати мають покривати спадкоємці.
Ми вважаємо це несправедливим.
Тож, адвокати радять кожному подбати заздалегідь про те,
хто опікуватиметься вашою віртуальною спадщиною.
Я принципово раджу усім завчасно думати про спадщину.
Один з варіантів - письмовий заповіт з вказанням того,
що робити з вашими цифровими даними у разі смерті.
Ви визначаєте того, кому довіряєте, і в ідеалі оформлюєте довіреність на його ім’я.
Дискусія про те, що робити із такою спадщиною у мережі, у Німеччині спалахнула після того,
як шість років тому в Берліні під колесами потяга метро загинула школярка.
Її рідним не давало спокою питання, було це нещасним випадком чи самогубством?
Щоб зрозуміти, чи цькували їхню дОньку, батьки хотіли зайти в її акаунт у Фейсбуці.
Однак їм це не вдалося, оскільки його перевели у статус,
яким позначають акаунти померлих.
Після тривалої тяганини Федеральний верховний суд Німеччини таки зобов’язав Facebook
надати батькам школярки доступ до її заблокованого акаунту.
Судді мотивували це тим,
що фотографії, переписка та приватні повідомлення прирівнюються до щоденників та листів,
які, за німецькими законами, переходять до спадкоємців померлого.